he's the dentist son who grew up to
become the world's youngest billionaire
in the mid-2000s Mark Zuckerberg created
a website that defined generation or
website you almost certainly use
yourself the BAM off that is Facebook
today it dominates the internet it has
more active users than the populations
of China and India combined at the time
of writing it's worth around half a
trillion dollars it's also at the center
of some massive controversies that have
dominated the headlines yep
how much do most of us know about the
man behind the business maybe you've
seen the movie The Social Network which
reimagines Mark Zuckerberg is a kind of
Lex Luthor of the internet using his
genius to crush his enemies there's
elements of truth to that to be sure
that the real Mark Zuckerberg is far
more interesting far more nuanced and
far more tragically flawed rich
brilliant idealistic this is the story
of how one privileged kid from small
town New York created a digital empire
only to see all is good intentions
collapse into dust
[Music]
if you were living among the clapboard
houses and leafy streets of Dobbs Ferry
New York in the mid-90s there would have
been one neighborhood kid who you were
sure was going to go far and that would
have been Mark Zuckerberg born in nearby
White Plains on may the 14th 1984 a
young mark was a veritable prodigy
taught Atari basic programming language
as a child but by age 12 he was creating
sprawling games from his friend's
childhood drawings by as mid-teens it
built an early messaging app called Zack
net that allowed the family to
communicate with his dad's dentistry
business online in real time when Mark
ended up transferring to the super
prestigious Phillips Exeter Academy for
a graduate computing course no one was
in the least bit surprised the
Zuckerberg had always been a family of
brain boxes dad Edward was a dentist and
mum Karen was a psychiatrist and the
family always encouraged learning in
their four children but Mark he was
something else a polyglot it taught
himself how to speak French Hebrew not
in the nation Greek he was captain of
the fencing team he devoured classic
literature along with a friends Adams
Angelo had even programmed a media
player so advanced that it sparked a
bidding war between Microsoft and AOL in
short mark was one of those privileged
kids you can tell are destined to
forever roll double sixes in the game of
life he had the talent to go far and he
had the competitive drive to on a form
around this time he actually listed
defeating nemesis as his hobby so when
this wound Akins lands into place at
Harvard in 2002 it was just another step
on that great long staircase of
privilege that led to the heaven of a
high-flying job and a home in the
Hamptons only this particular staircase
it came with a stumbling block this was
one that would initially trip 19-year
old mark hammer before accidentally
showing him how to climb far higher than
it ever dreamed the name of that block
well that was loneliness so here's the
thing about getting to Harvard as a
small-town genius you're suddenly
surrounded by other geniuses for the
first
in your life and some of those geniuses
might be so clever that you start to
look little less special and just a bit
more ordinary
in a 2008 profile Rolling Stone claims
that this was exactly what happened to
Mark Zuckerberg isolated I'm so many
other Harvard Brainiac C retreated into
programming abandoning his social life
for an online world where he could still
shine
he created a popular site called
coursematch for his fellow students
which gave him an insight into what made
people tick but course match it wasn't
the work of a genius it didn't even make
him stand out from the crowd as he so
desperately craved know he would have to
wait until his sophomore year to do that
because that was when he created a
little something known as face mash and
exploded Harvard Society in October 2003
Mark Zuckerberg sat in his dorm room
drunk and alone and consumed by
depression it just been jolted by one
Jessica a and like every young man
unlucky and loved he turned alcohol to
numb the pain of existence as he
morosely blogged about the bitch who had
betrayed him nineteen-year-old
Zuckerberg began flicking through
kirkland dorms Facebook that's Harvard
lingo for the online photo directories
of students that each dorm keeps his ego
winded Zuckerberg letters negative
thoughts flow into his blog some of
these people have pretty horrendous
Facebook pics
he wrote I almost wanted but some of
these faces next to pictures of farm
animals and deaf people vote on which is
more attractive the more alcohol
Zuckerberg consumes the more he began to
take the idea seriously maybe not with a
farm animals but why not put up two
pictures of students and have other
students vote on who was the hottest
before long Zuckerberg was thinking of
his idea is more than just a way of
lashing out at a world that had wounded
him it would be an epic prank one that
would no doubt go down in harvard
history by the early morning had
successfully hacked all of Harvard's
dorm directories scraping away private
user data and blogging about his prank
every step of the way before the Sun
rose Facemash it was live in no time at
all 450 people had viewed the site 22
times years later the 2010 movie the
social network would suggest Facebook
itself grew out of Facemash which isn't
quite true but Facemash does remain key
to understanding Zuckerberg the scale
and speed of the positive response to
his prank site it opened his eyes as he
would later say people are more
voyeuristic than I would have thought
it's a revelation he would soon leverage
into huge business success not that any
of that was guaranteed that cold October
night Facemash was only live for a few
hours before Harvard shut it down and
hit Zuckerberg with the mother of all
disciplinary actions he could be
suspended or even expelled and then what
would his mum and its dad think yes for
all of the stress that it caused him
Zuckerberg came out of the Facemash
debacle having gained something
invaluable
he was special again he was no longer a
nobody he was a computer genius and a
prankster hero Zuckerberg was even able
to leverage his newfound notoriety into
a date with the medical students called
Priscilla Chan and trust me
that is a name you are going to be
hearing again and again on November the
19th 2003 Harvard's Disciplinary Board
it dropped its privacy violation charges
against Zuckerberg the prankster bought
a bottle of champagne and cracked it
open with his roomies to celebrate
finally he had a place in the world
again all through 2003 Harvard had been
no campus that was buzzing with ideas
these were the heady days of web 2.0 and
social technologies were clearly gonna
be the next big thing all they needed
was for someone to harness them someone
with the brains and the talent to pull
technology and our human desire to
connect into the first great social
website someone like Divya Narendra and
some brilliant New York head of Indian
descent Narendra was in his junior year
at Harvard when he had a brainwave
imagine if you could take Harvard's many
Facebook's and combine them all into a
single site it would have a social
section a dating section and it would
combine all the advantages of real-life
interaction with the advantages of the
Facebook's the name thought narendra's
giant online Facebook while asked who is
Harvard connection
clearly narendra was not an adman still
he managed in april to rope in two
identical twins Tyler and Cameron
Winklevoss they were gonna act as his
money men his team in place Narendra now
just needed a computer guy to write the
code and pull everything together it was
at this point that the ambitious young
entrepreneur he heard about Facemash in
November of 2003 Narendra and the
winklevosses they contacted the now
notorious Mark Zuckerberg who asked if
he would help them in their project
Zuckerberg he jumped at the chance
emails from the time that were later
released are full of positivity he told
them it would take ten hours and that he
would be finished soon Narendra and his
cohorts they rubbed their hands with
glee it would only be a matter of time
before they were all filthy rich as
November ticked over into December
Zuckerberg abandoned his work on Harvard
connection still though he promised
Narendra that it would be finished soon
but he began to start work on his own
project this new project was a Harvard
connection but without all the extra
crap it would be won based on
psychological insights from Facemash On
January the 11th 2004 Zuckerberg quietly
registered the new site with his web
provider and with that of the
facebook.com appeared in the Internet's
records for the first time the very next
day
Zuckerberg approached his friend Eduardo
Saverin to help finance the project
Saverin agreed to front thousand dollars
he would later say that he only caved in
after Zuckerberg assured him that they'd
be able to use the new site to get laid
that January the 14th the Zuckerberg
finally stopped stringing Narendra along
in a face-to-face meeting he told him
that he needed to find a new programmer
Narendra pleaded with him to stay but
Zuckerberg he was already gone in the
last frantic weeks before the Facebook
launched it dawned on Zuckerberg that he
was going to fail a module on art in the
time of Augustus
therefore he hatched a classic
Zuckerberg scheme in no time at all he
knocked up a website and encouraged his
classmates to share materials on it
within 30 minutes of the site going live
had amassed enough material to function
as his own private crib sheet Zuckerberg
passed the module on February the 4th
2004 the facebook.com/ it finally went
live smart sleek and innovative it
looked sure to be the hottest new site
on campus as you already know though the
success of Zuckerberg and sovereign's
project it would not
confined to only Harvard the early days
of Facebook and now legendary over 4000
people signed up in the first two weeks
by May almost 200,000 people were on
board
these figures are still impressive today
but in the innocent days of 2004 they
were utterly phenomenal yet soccer
Berg's early success it was accompanied
by a strange defensive nurse in the
student paper the Harvard Crimson he
published an open letter describing how
he always went out of his way to help
people you know before wheeling around
and attacking Narendra with all guns
blazing by the end of the article had
managed to turn his own intellectual
property thefts into a scenario where he
was the victim not that anything about
Zuckerberg soured appearance screamed
victim summer he was renting an
apartment in Palo Alto and trying to
crack Silicon Valley one of his last
acts before leaving Harvard was to ask
Severin for an additional $20,000 for
the site and for him to join mark in
California Saverin said yes to the first
and no to the second this would not work
out well for him that June the first
Facebook headquarters appeared in a
house on a Jennifer way it was the punky
nerd mess that Zuckerberg had always
dreamed of the team spent all day
drinking beer and listening to Green Day
an all night programming Zuckerberg even
took to carrying around a fencing foil
sort of like a Zorro but reborn as an
entitled kid from New York State but it
would take something more to catapult
the new social network into the big time
something or maybe someone that someone
was Napster co-founder Justin Timberlake
not really that would be Sean Parker
he's played by Justin Timberlake in the
aforementioned movie Sean Parker just
happened to be living a few blocks away
from the never ending Facebook frat
party Parker was known to Zuckerberg
through Saverin who'd introduced them at
a dinner one day Zuckerberg just
happened to be walking past his house
when Parker came outside and the two
recognized one another now if you want
to pinpoint the moment when Zuckerberg
went from nerd with a dream zoo guy on a
course to becoming the world's youngest
billionaire well this is probably it
Parker became the Facebook's connection
to Silicon Valley's big money elite it
was a connection even Zuckerberg habit
of arriving at meetings in his pajamas
could not
in August PayPal co-founder Peter Thiel
became the site's first big investor
giving them a cash injection of $500,000
suddenly with that things they were
looking very serious and we mean that
here in more ways than one
around the time teal was coming on board
Saverin was not just being shown the
door but he was being thrown through it
in July of 2004 Saverin froze Facebook's
accounts after Zuckerberg failed to
match his $20,000 investment
Zuckerberg responded by transferring all
of the Facebook's assets to a new
version of the company that was
headquartered in Delaware this both cut
Saverin out and rendered his old stock
worthless Saverin would later say that
Zuckerberg screwed me by December of
2004 the Facebook was pulling in 1
million users Parker took over his
presidents and in early 2005 he forced
through a name change from this point on
the site would simply be known as
Facebook in May of that year venture
capital firm cell partners invested
twelve point seven million dollars in
Facebook the condition though was that
the company had to expand beyond just
the Ivy League schools that September
the site was opened to all colleges and
high schools across the United States by
Christmas there were five point five
million users and Zuckerberg well
Zuckerberg was riding a high Yahoo and
MTV Networks were both fighting to buy
stakes in the rising company and the
money was absolutely rolling in the one
major hiccup so far was that Parker had
had to resign after being allegedly
busted with cocaine at a party but
Facebook was still on a roll and really
the only way was up
by September of 2006 Facebook was open
to anyone with an email address which
set off a phenomenal growth spurt
but 2006 was also the year we got our
first real look at Mark Zuckerberg after
getting burned by his programmer back in
2004 narendra hadn't given up along with
the Winklevoss twins had launched a
massive lawsuit against zuckerberg that
came to a head just as Facebook was
conquering the planet unfortunately a
physical burg this meant a lot of things
from his past getting dragged up in
legal depositions over to excruciating
years the press slowly learned a locker
baguette offered users private Facebook
data to his friends Howard strung
Narendra along while stealing his idea
and how it even once harvested passwords
from Facebook tagged the email accounts
of journalists at the Harvard Crimson
who were sympathetic to Narendra it was
a litany of wrongdoing the sort of
scandal that could sink a lesser man but
Zuckerberg he was lucky data privacy
wasn't something that people really
cared about yet and he still had that
aura of rebellious cool it's hard now to
believe that Facebook ever had when he
eventually settled with Narendra out of
court for 65 million dollars the world
shrugged and went back to sharing cat
memes 5 2008 Facebook had become a
global phenomenon aged 23 Zuckerberg was
the youngest self-made billionaire in
history even as the rest of the planets
economy detonated in the financial
crisis Facebook it just kept on growing
as Zuckerberg had learned himself in his
miserable freshman year no one likes to
feel alone but if you think the rest of
this video is just going to be more of
Zuckerberg becoming richer while
casually stabbing colleagues in the back
well prepare yourself for a bit of a
twist while the Machiavellian Zuckerberg
is certainly a part of this story
there's another part to one we haven't
really touched on in the rush to get to
the narrative and that's Zuckerberg the
philanthropist it started with a hundred
million dollar donation in 2010 to save
Newark's public school system from
collapse that same year Zuckerberg signs
The Giving Pledge committing himself to
giving half of his fortune away to
charity by 2015 he and his future wife
who were going to live back to in a
moment would be giving 99 percent of
their fortune to charitable causes which
was a record amount it's here we really
get to
heart of what makes Zuckerberg tick and
that all of the manipulation and
scandals it's worth remembering that at
heart he's an idealist he really does
want to make the world a better place
whether through giving or encouraging us
all to connect via Facebook but he had
soon set his sights even higher
Zuckerberg didn't just want to change
the world incrementally he wanted to
actively shape it to push everyone
towards a better future whether they
wanted to go there or not
ironically it would be this noble
impulse that soon set him and his
company on the road to PR disaster in
October of 2014
Mark Zuckerberg stepped out of a bright
orange helicopter in the tiny Indian
village of chandu Ali
it was a hot day the air pregnant with
humidity but Zuckerberg had more in his
mind than the heat he was in Chen duly
to change the world it had been a good
four years to be Mark Zuckerberg in 2012
it married his longtime love Priscilla
Chan exactly one day after Facebook who
gone public for the first time barely a
year after that he would become a father
then there's the philanthropic work that
February Zuckerberg unveiled something
called internet.org which was later
renamed free basics vision for planet
Earth where everyone would have access
to an internet connection connectivity
is a human right it stated he was in
India to make that vision a reality
the idea that Zuckerberg pitch to the
schoolchildren of Chen Dooley that
October it was simple a free version of
the internet that would give them access
to 36 sites including of course Facebook
as he left the village to cheers and got
back in his private helicopter
Zuckerberg he must have felt like he was
doing God's work bringing digital
civilization to the internet barbarians
of rural India only not everyone saw it
that way in fact to some Indian tech
journalists it sounded a lot like free
basics violated net neutrality indeed
they kind of saw it as little more than
digital era colonialism Zuckerberg could
of course have countered this narrative
by listening to the concerns of these
writers but he didn't instead he does
what had done with Saverin and narendra
role
years ago he struck first miss this was
a bad move the scan of Facebook's
attacks stunned journalists The Guardian
reports that the site automatically
enrolls the profiles of users into its
anti net neutrality petitions at one
point even signing up those who'd been
dead for two years as one Indian
journalist put it Facebook came and
shoved its arse in our faces the
campaign was so manipulative that it
galvanized India against Facebook in
February of 2016 the country effectively
outlawed free basics now in the normal
run of things this would have just been
one misstep in the life of a company one
more disaster that would simply be
chalked up to experience but here's the
thing about the free basics debacle
Zuckerberg he didn't learn all he took
away was that when the next scandal hit
he would have to fight even harder and
it wasn't long before the next scandal
arrived not six months later BuzzFeed's
editor Craig Silverman noticed a string
of false stories emerging from one small
town in Macedonia but blowing up big
time across all of Facebook nearly all
involved the presidential candidate
Donald Trump strangely the stories and
the sites they linked do seem to be
multiplying and not all of them came
from Macedonia as the campaign season
dragged on others started to emerge from
further east specifically from Russia
two years before an engineer at Facebook
had raised the alarm about unusual
levels of activity coming from Russia
but his reports it had just been
dismissed people were wondering whether
the Russians were using Facebook to
spread propaganda Zuckerberg he didn't
think so on November the 10th for just
two days after Donald Trump's shock win
in the bitterly contested election he
made a speech calling those worried
about fake news on his website crazy but
he wasn't telling the whole truth
Facebook's own analysis published in
2017 would reveal russian-backed
propaganda groups that reached a hundred
and twenty six million Americans during
the election rather than be concerns
though Zuckerberg and his board they
issued denials on January the 6th 2017
the CIA declared that Russia had
interfered in the election and that
social media particularly Facebook had
played a major role outwardly Zuckerberg
and his
they simply kept on repeating their
denials but behind the scenes panic it
was beginning to set in throughout April
Facebook launched a crackdown on fake
news hoping to pull out ahead of the
scandal but by now it was too late by
July Zuckerberg was claiming no evidence
existed that Russian actors bought
Facebook ads Sony for hard evidence to
emerge in September that indeed they did
that yom kippur he recorded a public
video asking for forgiveness
apparently hopes this new contrite
approach would soothe over the latest
scandal unfortunately an even bigger
scandal was already waiting in the wings
on March the 17th 2018 a joint report by
The Guardian The New York Times and
Britain's channel 4 revealed that a firm
known as Cambridge analytical had used
third-party apps to harvest the data of
80 million Facebook users and that data
had been used to try and influence votes
everywhere from the u.s. to Great
Britain to Mexico this data didn't just
come from users who'd stupidly installed
these apps some of the apps
automatically harvested the data of
their friends as well crucially
Zuckerberg he was aware of this Facebook
launched its Open Graph software in
April of 2010 specifically to sell data
including the contents of private
messages by the way to advertisers in
May of that year
Zuckerberg he wrote an op-ed in the
Washington Post addressing users
concerns but nothing was done about it
until 2014 and even then the changes
they weren't applied retroactively Li
any company like Cambridge analytical
that already had its claws into your
data they didn't have to let go the
resulting scandal had exploded like a
small bomb staining the reputations of
both Facebook and Mark Zuckerberg over
ten years after it first used data from
the Facebook to hack the emails of
Harvard Crimson journalists Zuckerberg
was in trouble over data privacy yet
again only this time he had to testify
on Capitol Hill on March the 20th 2018
the Federal Trade Commission had
launched an inquiry into Facebook Great
Britain the EU and others had set up
similar investigations that spring Mark
Zuckerberg privately told the Facebook
board that his company was now at war
yet still the scandals didn't stop at
the time of this video is recording
Facebook as a company lurching from
scandal to scandal dragging its founder
in its wake among other things Acker
Berg's digital utopia has been accused
of facilitating ethnic cleansing in
Myanmar aiding the harassment of
survivors of mass shootings and
spreading negative propaganda about
George Soros aged only 34 Mark
Zuckerberg has finally lost whatever
veneer of cool he and his creation once
had rich powerful and utterly convinced
of his own rightness he has refused
calls to step down from Facebook's board
or do anything but keep on fighting
isolated in the eye of a growing
hurricane of scandal he no longer seems
like the punk nerd who upended
communication but like King Lear raging
at the sky as his world crumbles around
him
Zuckerberg story it's not Avery's not
yet 40 but his biography as it stands
today is a one of warning a strange
morality tale of hubris theft and
misplaced good intentions for our
internet age whether the final act is
one that ends in Mark Zuckerberg
Redemption or his damnation is something
only time will tell
so I really hope you enjoyed the video
if you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos several days
a week so hit that subscribe button in
the notification bell so you actually
find out about these videos subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube and as always thank you for
watching